ice has builders than carved the world
we know on a colossal scale what is it
that gives something as brittle as ice
supremacy or the hardest and most
resilient rocks to be found on the
planet to find out you need to see
inside a Glacia
thus partisan glacier in Norway is one
of the few places on earth where ice can
really be seen in action it's thanks to
this glacier that scientists are
starting to understand the secrets of
ices great power deep beneath the
glacier and a chamber at the end
scientists come face-to-face with ice
then it's two days of hard work using
hot water to melt Hakeem beg enough to
get inside the glacier and see it in all
its glory
here's a sternal watch your head
maryam jackson's a glaciologist she
spends up to three weeks at a time down
here it's beautiful it's amazing isn't
it it's absolutely beautiful
this is like a piece of art this is it
isn't it Wow we go remember this 200
meters of ice August now 200 meters
yes normally glassy and Isis or MERS is
also closing in on us as we speak it's
kids contract an airline yeah if we
consented for 48 hours the ice would
close in on us
we simply fossilized in the ice up
against cue it's down here right at the
very bottom of the glacier you can see
how it carves out great landscapes and
can slice through solid rock
it's not the ice itself that does all
the damage
it's the debris that it picks up along
the way that makes glaciers act like
giant sand paper an effect the ice uses
the rock against itself but the ice cave
has another surprise
Soniya bubble is it it's not look this
is real oh yeah look at that so this is
we open this up when we were a little
melting I thought before then it was
totally enclosed in the ice these water
pockets apparently make the ice less
brittle so it can band around obstacles
in the landscape
iglesia is not the solid mass that it
first appears seeing it from the insight
has given me a completely different
perspective it seems almost alive as if
to prove the point the ice invades a
space we've left behind in just three
days our magical ice cave disappears
you